Bill uh what's the latest yeah good
evening to you interrupt me anytime you
want okay I got a lot to show you right
now show our viewers at home as to where
we stand uh New Hampshire's counting
slow tonight and I say that Sean because
you've got about a third of the vote in
and I I I don't know if that has
something to do I'm guessing here now
with a democratic right in vote because
if I flip over the Democratic race again
we declar Joe Biden to be the winner uh
but you're just about 40% right there I
I I don't know if that has something to
do uh with the slow down but it could be
all right you're 33% reporting in I'm
going to flip through a bunch of stuff
here Sean and try to explain a little
bit about maybe what's happening out
there and as I do that just this
estimated vote that's is in just keep
keep that number in mind okay to the
folks at home in New Hampshire 70% of
those who vote in the State live in four
counties and they're all in the southern
part of the state and we're going to go
through those right now okay right on
the border here with Massachusetts it's
Hillsboro's County uh population 30% of
all the New Hampshire at ranks one out
of 10 okay right you see that you're 32%
Donald Trump percentage wise leads by 12
points in Hillsboro County seem to be a
good number for the Trump team uh
conversely over here in Rockingham
County so your population R you're two
out of 10 now for the whole state um you
got a lot of that boat out right now
Sean you're at 16% Trump holds on to a
six-point lead in Rockingham County if I
were to take back eight years ago listen
the entire race was different then I
grant you that you had 10 Republicans
but in Rockingham County against nine
other Republicans Trump faed pretty well
you shy of 39% let's come back to Modern
days right now let's go to coner this is
maram County again here's the number 40%
so still a lot of vote out there right
now Trump has a slight Edge over Nikki
Haley by two points when I checked this
about 10 minutes ago Haley was leading
in marac where you find the capital city
of conquer one other County for the 70%
that I mentioned uh this is straford
County okay so uh they're counting
quicker right that that's 67% you're
23ds in Trump leads Nikki Haley in this
County by 11 points at 55 to 45 so
that's what's happening right now as I
scan the state now with regard to
Democrats I want to explain something
right now and take you back in time
that's going to say a lot about right
now about maybe what the Democratic
challenge is uh for Joe Biden okay so we
talked about this uh Biden the right in
candidate Dean Phillips still hanging in
there at 20% somewhat impressive I would
argue if I were to come out of this Sean
and take you uh do a little history
lesson okay so this is got it okay this
is the Democratic
outcome uh for
2020 Bernie Sanders and Pete Buddha
judge it ran all across the state all
right well where was Joe Biden in that
race he was fifth at 8%
if I were to take you a week prior to
that in the Iowa caucus back in 2020 it
was Bernie Sanders and Pete budzz right
Joe Biden is not there in the gold um
silver or bronze he was at fourth place
just shy of 14% so then Biden made a
calculation when he was here in New
Hampshire he left before the tally came
out he did not go to Nevada he went to
South Carolina in about 17 days after
New Hampshire results
this is what happened on leap day of
2020 Joe Biden shy of 50% that
catapulted and past um Bernie Sanders
led him on this tear across the country
for the remaining states he became the
nominee and later became the president
so now then uh we're going to head to
South Carolina in about a month's time
and on the Republican side that is when
the race will be held if Nikki Haley
continues with the current position that
she announced here just a short short
time ago on the calendar here is how it
shakes down okay you're in January we
had two big contests right now New
Hampshire still playing out as I showed
you and we're going to tick in the
February this matters for Republicans
Nevada caucus all right Donald Trump's
competing he's probably going to take
all the delegates uh from that caucus
that night at 26 uh Nikki Haley elected
for the primary it's it's a confusing
matter they split it up it is what it is
but the caucus will matter then you get
to South Carolina okay we're going to
see the measure of strength right now in
South Carolina the 50 delegates out
there because as we started the night
here hang with me one second here I'll
show you this this is where we started
the night you 1215 delegates get the
nomination Trump took 20 out of Iowa Des
santis took nine he dropped out as you
know a couple days back and Nikki Haley
was at eight she's going to get some
delegates tonight but this contest could
go on sometime if Nikki Hy the former
Governor and Ambassador who worked for
Donald Trump uh during his his term in
the White House chooses to stay in and
that's where we are Sean all right Bill
Hammer at the big board tonight we'll be
checking back in with you throughout the
evening hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else